you live in Phoenix yes I could Brennan
you know what Scott they don't say this
right now I've been here for 25 years in
Los Angeles
if you said Brian pack a bag you got to
go to a lake in Austin Texas or you got
to go to Arizona
I wouldn't [ __ ] I look back I I
wouldn't I said on Saturday I wouldn't
miss this [ __ ] place hey tough guy I
wouldn't miss this Falk in place I said
those exact things on Saturday said pack
your bag you're the only reason I'm
still in LA I know I knew it while you
figured this out the kids all right but
you just said if I said that you'd go
you're the only reason I'm still in LA
let's let rogue and be the canary in the
coalmine let's let him kind of figure
out figure Texas out or wherever it is
he's gonna go and then we'll you know I
always say Joe you go do all the work
and we'll come over and then he could
buy us houses not if he wants us close
to him he should buy his house it's no
pop I get my own money you might need
that I know how about you get your
little guest house I'll be on pool boy
dr. rules walking around room
let's dejected as soon as you say you
can go to Texas I'll buy a house
[ __ ] you're the only reason I'm still no
I think about I'm the only reason I had
to talk with Showtime to air you know
Malka was they can shoot below the belt
everything the whole squad would be down
to girl feels it was like I'm not
married la what if there's a massive
exodus a comedic exodus that goes to
Austin I'm just sick of the [ __ ] around
here oh why the traffic and the [ __ ]
the homeless % to some homeless student
homeless my coffee shop you ever see you
ever see human sure you ever see Nancy
Pelosi's [ __ ] district in in San
Francisco
yeah take a look at it it's just
homeless as far as the eye can see
how's that gone she's a [ __ ] they're
all just like I don't know man Gavin
Newsom how'd you do in San Francisco
right now again and Pelosi would beat up
Garcetti though Teddy's a giant why I
don't know look I don't know what it's
like to run a massive economy like this
but I think they're not doing now I'm
talking about
so funny how it's so funny how if you
think government's the answer take a
look at the [ __ ] homeless crisis it's
hilarious
yes it's a [ __ ] it's yeah but
remember you're like - dude if you tell
me all right well I'm telling you as
soon as you say hey the way everybody's
down
we'll start the shopping yep I'm going
yeah when I'm in San Antonio don't be
surprised if during the week during the
day you're me at Hotel Emma and I'm
telling you to call me as soon as you're
walking - oh let's move here I
understand but I'm gonna drive the 45
minutes one hour to Austin and I'm going
to go and look at Braun's interview I'm
in San Antonio June 25 26 27 yes
is that the same time I'm spoken that's
a ten day Tuesday Friday Saturday
yeah well Spokane is up in the air when
a fortune 526 so I'm gonna drive down to
Austin I'm gonna say it again please
25 26 means oh I need a broker oh yeah a
good broker because they were supposed
to mean oh spoken there was a little bit
of a scare who's got a good broker in
Austin oh I'll talk to Robin I'll tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]